[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are talking all about
what we call our other best friend
the trio that was Rhett link and Ben Ben
Greenwood our childhood friend who we've
talked about on and off from time to
time he's come up a lot but we're gonna
devote an entire episode to talking
about Ben yeah I this is an important
episode for us I mean maybe I I hope it
will be for you to listening because I
mean whether it's a childhood friend or
someone that you meet along the way in
your life I think that there are there
are people that have an impact on your
life and sometimes it's not until you
look back on all those shared
experiences can you really piece
together how deep that impact goes so
I'm looking forward to this episode over
the Y I was gonna say years I guess over
the years there's been times when I've
thought I want to I want to do what
we're doing today I wanna I want to talk
about our our friendship with Ben and
just pull it all together just for the
sake of under taking away even more from
it and appreciating even more I I hope
that's what happens today and yeah
because we've you know we've talked
about and we have as we're about to
demonstrate incorporated Ben into our
work we've also talked about you know he
just he was such an influence on us and
the way that we lived our lives as kids
which has translated into the way that
we live our lives as adults which I
think yeah it's all about mythicality
such absolute like yeah when we wrote
our book of mythicality which if if you
don't know we we wrote a book it's it's
it's part coffee table Audubon Rafi lots
of stories lots of illustrations to get
it get it for somebody
get it for yourself I didn't mean get it
get it for yourself you know when you
said get it for somebody makes it sound
like I only get it as a gift
I assume you do you won't enjoy it yeah
when we set out to write this thing and
we defined what mythicality meant but
you know what I'm gonna read it the
quality or state of being that embodies
a synergistic coalescence of curiosity
creativity and tomfoolery sometimes
referred to as curio tomfoolery I didn't
even say that right sometimes referred
to as curio Tom foo Livity mm-hmm for
liberty ideally experienced in the
context of friendship and intended to
bring goodwill to the universe we worked
on that a definition for quite some time
and we and we we worked on this book for
a long that's what we're about y'all if
you want to know what Rhett links about
that's about curio tomfool Livity right
and we dedicated this book in memory of
Ben Greenwood his friendship changed our
lives but ended way too soon and there's
a picture of the three of us together
right there
so of course we we dedicated the book to
Ben because of how he embodied
mythicality
and then I think we talked about him a
little bit more in in the in the book
but the thing that we really did the way
we brought Ben to life in a character is
the character who have been in our novel
the lost causes the Bleak Creek this
isn't like a rhettandlink book promo
time this is about Ben but we have to do
this to establish the context but yes we
wrote a novel last year loss causes a
bleak Creek and our favorite character
besides of course Rex and leaf no
actually our international favorite
character in the book is Ben who is
based on Ben Greenwood yeah read the UM
the acknowledgement in the back there
this isn't a lot because this this novel
was dedicated to our kids right
dedicated to our kids but there's a long
list of people that we acknowledged and
thanked in the end
our childhood friend Ben Greenwood for
leading us into constant adventure and
fearlessly embodying mythicality and all
that life held for you you gave us the
tree the rocks and the river and if
you've read the book or heard of still
lots of stories about these things you
know what a tree the rocks in the river
are I one of the first stories that I I
think about is damming the creek yeah so
I am interested in if you remember the
first time you met BIM but I'd love to
I'd love to talk about this story first
because I think in a lot of ways it's it
kind of we have a lot of memories and
we'll go through a lot of them but that
one it just it really encapsulates well
he was as a person yeah I don't have I
think I can talk about meeting Ben for
the not the I don't have a story about
meeting Ben but I can just tell you
quickly because he was him he was in my
class in third grade and you cuz you
were in a different class in third grade
that year miss hoods class right I think
it might have been fourth grade then we
were in Miss hoods class together
Oh Everhart was the year that we weren't
in the same class fourth fourth grade
but I don't know is that when Ben moved
to town first year was third grade miss
Hodes okay okay yeah we were in that
class together but because he looked
pretty close to me yeah he lived inside
of Keith Hills I live right outside to
keep those so I think I ended up kind of
playing with him first yeah yeah
but I just remember my impression of
this guy first of all you I've talked
about this before but unlike you at that
age I was very much like Ike meet you
and then that night I asked if I can
spend a night at your house like I
invited myself over to something I'm not
and I'm more introverted now and would
never do that but as a kid I got to know
people and immediately invited myself I
was like so I gots been in the night
your house ready in discriminatory yeah
and and so that was what I did with Ben
and I think as a new kid in town he was
like yeah I got a friend and I just
found this guy and his family to be so
interesting you know they were they were
from Oklahoma they had moved from
Oklahoma and the way been talked about
Oklahoma made me think that Oklahoma was
a magical land of milk and lace he
talked about giant catfish that could
eat children and then he would talk he
talked about his grandfather and he was
this is something that now I've kind of
seen multiple kids do in different
movies and stuff but the way he talked
about his grandfather was as if his
grandfather was the biggest baddest
badass in town who could beat up anybody
including his own dad and just he was
like he would just talk about his
grandfather like his grandfather was
this larger-than-life
guy who knew everything and it was
incredibly strong like the strength of
Ben's grandfather was something that was
legendary I was like and you know this
is before the age of information like in
the internet was just kind of get cut
couldn't Google his grandfather to
validate these clean put in Google
Oklahoma and be like oh Oklahoma is just
a state above Texas that shaped like a
pot right you know nothing against
Oklahoma but it's just another state
it's it's as magical as any other state
but it's pretty flat
he had a way of making yes his
imagination was replaying magical and
yeah I was immediately captivated and it
was like I want to be around this kid
his dad his family was interesting
because his dad was a professor at
Campbell just like your dad right he was
a biology professor am i right I think
he was in the who's in the pharmacy
school maybe or maybe biology I think
they all had the same building he was in
the Society of the scientific discipline
of some sort yes okay but the but the
behind his house was was a whole stretch
of woods and Ben would always go out
into the woods and I remember when the
three of us started hanging out about
every I don't know I got the impression
that about every three to five times
that you guys would hang out I would
also be there because I had farther to
come and you know right
and you were you were you were a little
scared of things at that time just did
that yeah and you you always been a
little bit scared of things Ben was not
scared
vini he wasn't scared of any I mean he
was always gallivanting through the
woods and there was a if you go deep
enough into the woods there was a creek
that ran and actually we didn't it was
buoy screams booyah that ran back there
and just like all the other times there
was something crazy that we embarked
upon it was most likely Ben's idea at
this point to build a dam to dam the
creek in order to what make a little
pond that then efficient it put fish
stock it with the stock upon and also to
build a raft to raft oak throughout our
pond so we so we did all three of these
things and it not indifferent all the
same time but so we went back there and
we dedicated an entire day like beavers
man just taking rocks taking logs taking
everything we could scrounge up and well
we found a plot you know with the give
you know into the creeks like Buies
Creek when it was just typically flowing
this is one of those creeks that's
probably like ten feet across
you know maybe 20 feet in some places
maybe five feet in other places but in
the middle of the summer it's not
flowing
you can basically walk across it if you
find a good spot you can walk across on
some rocks without you maybe it may be a
couple of feet deep at the deepest point
but if you find one of those places that
like a log is already kind of across the
creek and there's some rocks you know oh
I can add a little bit to this and we
could be beavers and build our own damn
it's just you know my kids don't know
what to do today
you know we're not damming it's like
well if they're not on you know I don't
want to get into that the kids go out
and dam a creek now it's like oh my god
they're on the news three teens damn
Creek we spent like Sun up to Sun Sun
down in this endeavor and we we dammed
the creek yep for like a few minutes uh
no okay in my recollection
we went and caught fish from the pond
and brought them down hey you might have
done that on another day but because I
do remember that it didn't hold well I
think that maybe the first time when we
did
with you it was we we went we revisited
the plan because yeah eventually it was
just like we're not beavers you know I'm
saying I want as much as I want to be a
beaver sometimes yeah I'm not a beaver
and I don't understand the damn math you
know which is the math of dams and right
the physics of dams maybe and the whole
thing just collapsed but there was a
time in which we would we dammed it went
down to the creek caught some like
crappie I mean we would catch all kinds
of crappie yeah down there he fished a
lot there were a lot of I mean the the
creek emptied into a series of ponds
that basically man-made ponds for the
golf course for the keys of golf course
we fished down there all the time you
can catch some bass some bream and some
crappy we got some crappy put him in a
bucket brought him up put him in there
they swam around for a little bit and in
the dam broke again because that's what
happened mr. dams I wasn't much of a
fisherman so I kind of yeah a lot of my
time spent with Ben was fishing because
he was an outdoorsman he was because we
also we cut you know we've talked about
this about how we would just find a tree
and cut it down sometimes just going and
finding a tree just selecting a tree in
the woods and spinning all day with an
axe trading off cutting down this giant
tree which is incredibly dangerous not
to mention not really environmentally
responsible because we were just
timbering one tree but he owned nothing
ax yeah and he sharpened his axe and he
invited us to trudge into the woods pick
the perfect tree and it was a big one
again this is an all-day endeavor taking
training off chopping this thing down
it was absolutely exhausting right and
while there was four hours of not
talking yeah just chopping but we
learned like we learned like oh if you
want to cut on a tree like you just
don't you got to like Cree you got to
like come in from the top at an angle
yet ago in from the bottom at an angle
like we kind of learned by just doing
how you chop down a tree I mean I
haven't had to use that skill yet again
but in your target and we're talking
like seventh grade
maybe sixth grade right but with the
wrath thing we've been cut down a tree
about that big a pine tree okay and
he cut it up and then we took ropes and
we tied it together and then we tried to
float it on the pond I wasn't and the
whole thing came apart as soon as we
tried to float it like we'd ropes when
we tried to get on it it was like this
isn't stable and I can get it to you if
I was there it still wouldn't worked you
know but he just he would build a
lean-to right well yeah so that's a
that's one of my favorite stories about
Ben is the time that he there was a an
empty lot across well it basically woods
across the street from his house now
I've gone back you know in the past
couple years and now that whole side of
the street in Keith Hills is filled with
houses but for a long time it was just
woods yeah and he said I go to his house
he's like I think we should build an
a-frame mmm and I'm like yeah I have no
idea what the hell in a frame it but I'm
like yeah that's right a frame let's do
it
okay and so again the thing that was so
mysterious about Ben was in a day before
the Internet how did people learn things
he just learned things in books he just
I guess he just went to the library
which none but nobody else was doing it
would just be like I got this but I know
how to build an a-frame I don't even
know what part I it wasn't until we
finished and it was an a-frame by
looking at it from the side that was
like Oh a frame the whole time I was
like yeah a frame then I was like
where's the a but we spent all day
building this thing out of two by fours
and then oh not Latin limbs no we use
two by fours as the braces of this thing
okay and like nailed them together but
then we got sticks again the whole time
I'm kind of acting like I know what
we're doing you know I'm saying like I'm
there I'm helping but I'm kind of like
waiting to see him do something then to
know what we're doing and he probably
knew all of this and then we put sticks
big sticks on it lean them up against
each other then smaller sticks and then
we made a giant pit of mud and then
started putting the mud on top of all
the sticks and then put leaves on top of
that and like straw
and grass and stuff yeah Ben was like
that guy from primitive what's it called
that YouTube channel primitive
technology man of technology yeah he
would be that guy if he had a YouTube
channel and so he he we did this and
then of course he was like we're gonna
do this and then we're gonna sleep in
their camp and so that night after we
finished the thing we like kind of like
cleaned out underneath it we put our
sleeping bags under there and we camped
in this a-frame and I just thought this
is the coolest thing I've ever done and
every everything that been set out to do
was the coolest thing yeah well in that
a frame for many many many years we
probably did that in like fifth grade
even when I would come back home from
college oh I would go out there and be
like man they're still like I mean I
wouldn't sleep under there anymore but
like there's like mud the roof is kind
of still intact it was like it was it
was an a-frame man it held up so I mean
if you've read the lost causes of Bleak
Creek now you see the connection between
a kid who can escape from a reform
school and instead of going back home to
his parents just lit subsists on his own
in the woods yeah the world's it's not
something that we made up yeah he could
have easily done all that I remember you
two taking me out to this a-frame which
in my mind it was a lean-to but I guess
it leaned on the other two-lane to
itself yeah made it a and then you said
would you want would you like to smoke a
big George and I'm like I'm afraid yeah
so again this this idea came from the
fact that Ben was so like again he's
reading some book and he's like hey you
want to make some juniper tea yes oh we
got to go get these juniper bushes and
we got him put them in water and steep
it and make tea and it tasted like
absolute crap it was horrible made you
want to vomit but he would have these
things that he would make that were
sort of the my side of the mountain my
side of the mountain was my favorite
book growing up and I kind of saw Ben as
that I wanted to be that kid but I saw
Ben as the kid yeah
who could do these things next I lived
in a hollowed-out hollow tree
and so we have we had done all this
stuff and it hadn't necessarily tasted
good or whatever but then in that same
woodsy area over there we built the
a-frame there were these stalks of it
was like a week it was like a weed that
basically was like bamboo like it bridge
it was a rigid sort of like sectioned
off bamboo like shaft and it would dry
it dried up it was very hard yeah it
would it would grow and then it would
die and snap it off snap it off and then
I don't look I I mean I I'm gonna give
Ben the credit on this one he can take
it one day he decided what if we smoked
this like a but he it wasn't like a list
smoked this like let's smoke weed it was
more like let's smoke this like a peace
pipe yeah like it was more like a Native
American type thing lining something in
the earth and smoking it but it I mean
it was a hollow it device that could be
used for smoking if you put something in
it that was worth smoking but we didn't
you offered it to me it was empty and
you just lift the end of it you lit the
end with a mat so you suck the smoke
through and it was acrid smoke in a big
gorge man we didn't do anything for you
except make you cough a lot well yeah
and when you asked me to do it I do
remember that neither one of you were
also doing it it wasn't we've we've done
this right George but I mean I just felt
this great sense of privilege to be
hanging out with you guys when it was
like oh man you've built this thing and
I'm getting invited to be a part of this
it's like I mean on one hand I was like
man I'm I'm missing out on some fun but
like I'm glad to be here whatever on the
days that he wasn't carrying around an
ass
he would always carry around a machete
Shetty and then we each went get went to
wombling sons and bought our own
machetes because you're going to there's
no paths unless you make them and we
would always go explore the woods and
there would be these huge vines that
would grow up into the trees and the
vines would I mean it would be as bigger
around than a silver dollar some of them
will be huge is an interesting
measurement big around is a silver
dollar
those were them a silver dollar diameter
is the perfect diameter I think we're a
little bit bigger than that in fact I'll
tell I have the story of something that
happening on a vine that we will tell
you in just one second but first we're
gonna let you know that you can get this
oh we're a new shirt that Lincoln oh
yeah it did the middle of a story yeah
well I was a TI added a teaser and yeah
this is a I was a teenage mythical beast
this is our homage to can we I mean it's
really an homage to Teen Wolf but it's
knock and say that it's not Teen Wolf
you know because it's like copyright
it's an original creation ethical Keira
teenage mythical beast so we would go
into the woods with our machetes and
you're not just chopping down to make a
path but you see these vines growing up
and you chop the bottom and then you'll
walk you grab it and you walk aways
until it starts to getting so taut and
you know it's like because it's it's
anchored up into the top of the tree and
then you just you jump and you swing
like Tarzan and around the Cape Fear
River and around Buies Creek all behind
Ben's house the place was full of these
vines and if you found the exact right
diameter and you found it anchored to
the right tree with the right topography
you could swing just an epic distance we
found one when we were back in Buies
Creek but I don't think it made the Edit
we didn't have a machete we didn't have
anything to cut it at the bottom and
then the one that we found was it was
broken and then when there when it that
oh yeah once you once you cut the vine
we actually had these theories about can
you cut the vine and can we bring a
bucket of water and set the vine in the
bucket of water till make the vine live
longer so we can swing on it more yeah
but I was always super you know worried
because I was always the biggest and
heaviest one so you know that if the
vines gonna break its gonna break on the
big boy your dad had instilled this
awareness or maybe even a fear of injury
because you know you were a burgeoning
basketball star at least in your mind in
the minds of all those in Harnett County
take the bone take the base so I
remember it because I was yeah I was
already in high school this time yeah
and it was when they were beginning to
sort of clear out the the area that then
eventually became the second 18 holes
for Keith Hills but they we didn't know
what they were doing but it was like a
kind of a weird dirt road that they I
kind of cut through the woods yeah this
is one of our last vine-swinging
adventures this is the last time I swung
on a line and like you said you find the
right topography so it was perfect it
was there was a there was a hill and the
tree that had the vine on it was right
next to this road that was going
downhill
dirt dirt road and we cut the vine and
then you guys started swinging and it
was like it was magical but because it
was kind of thing that you could go
really high up on this hill and then
swing and then at you're your pinnacle
at your peak you guys were probably
eight feet off the ground ten feet off
the ground if not 50 and I was I was
nervous because again is probably like
sophomore or junior year I'm like well
into thinking I'm gonna play college
basketball and I was always worried at
that point about getting injured and I
was like but I can't say no to this
perfect vine hmm so I swung and I was in
the middle of just like this euphoric
meeting the end of the pendulum and my
like I was up on the violin my knees
were in the air that was also a mistake
because it at its pinnacle the vine just
completely gave away I mean I kept it in
my hands
right you hold the vine the whole time
but it's like no longer holding on to
whatever your agent needed to and I come
down on that dirt road on my tailbone oh
gosh I remember seeing it happen and I
remember the noise you made do you
member to all the words I remember
although I I said I unleashed a high
rate of profanity was I we cursed at
times but like I cursed so much in a
span of about 30 seconds and I was like
I think I broken my back I think I broke
my tailbone and it's my theory that my
back problems that's when they started
but you know it was all worth it I think
I probably compressed some some discs at
that point Ben had a canoe he would take
the canoe on the Cape for a river and
his parents god bless him would we put
the canoe on top of the car and we we
drive all the way to Lillington or
sometimes all the way to Raven Rock and
they just we'd say they say bon voyage
and then they'd say we'll pick you up
and eat a boys Creek or way down in
Erlin like six hours later well that
well if you did all of that if we that
was the day we went to Buckhorn damn
though was it that was one that took
hours and hours so but we would do all
stretches of the river in this canoe and
three boys in a canoe it's like I it was
amazing
later we ended up buying kayaks Ben
didn't get one for reasons we'll get
into but like the love for the river and
you know we've talked about it so much
and I was swimming in the river crossing
the river to get it guy did he get a
count yeah yeah because he could
actually he was the only one who could
roll it over that is right
yeah I don't I don't know what I forgot
that our love for the river was because
Ben was the one who always wanted to be
there and said yeah we can take a canoe
out on there this is something that we
can do he never thought of an idea and
then said now we can't do that he would
think of an idea and we would just do it
and you know the interesting thing is I
think that there was a because I will
say you know I I I give Ben the credit
for
or being the one that kind of like
sparked this sort of sense of adventure
and sense of imagination but I also I
want to recognize just the fact that I
think he could have done that he could
have done that with other kids he would
have not responded to it who would write
like but we were we were on board oh
yeah
it was very much and that we kind of
kept that same spirit like it's like I
don't resonate I don't know how to do
this he didn't have to talk us into
anything but it was very much like yes
we're here for this yes let's go to
Buckhorn damn there was we never stopped
to ask the question is this a good idea
is this safe might we die and I think if
we had a stopped and asked those
questions we probably would have a
number of things that we wouldn't have
done I'm glad we didn't ask those
questions we're very fortunate that we
got out with that willing minor injuries
but yeah we were completely on board for
all this stuff many times when we would
go out and chase cows he would be there
chasing cows right along with us yeah
there's we told those stories before he
had a trampoline and he was very he was
so like skinny but he was pretty
athletic and very odd very daring and he
would do all of these flips and stuff on
these on the trampoline and he made up
this terminology where I guess all kids
do this on the trampoline when you jump
really high and then you when you're in
the air you pivot and then you land on
your back and you bounce off of your
back and come back up but he called this
a blu-ray blu-ray yeah because I think
that's the sound he made when all of the
air was forced out of his lungs as he
impacted with the trampoline blew so he
he had a way of contextualizing and
inventing ways to think about things
that all kids were doing that elevated
it so it wasn't just let's come over
let's jump on the trampoline it's like
no less master the art of a balloon
well and I don't know if you I assume
you were here for some of this we spent
a lot once the trampoline happened we
spent a lot of time on the trampoline
like days just on the trampoline
figuring out things coming up with moves
but one of the things he also did is put
a tarp over the trampoline and then get
dish soap and put it all over the tarp
and then get a hose and wet it down and
then the trampoline was at a slight
angle which is very safe and we would
run dive onto the trampoline slide
completely off of it like slide
completely over it and then off the
other side into the woods I remember
this it was one of those tramadol where
those Springs were exposed to if I
remember Yeah right we didn't have a net
I don't know how you went across the
springs but you did know well because
they were covered with a tarp that's
right the whole thing was covered with
the tarp and I didn't help that you kind
of sort of hit the bar and the springs
on the other side but there was many we
get we went through this phase did you
ever spend the night with us out there
on the trampoline yeah we would we went
through we stopped like using the
a-frame because it like kind of the
grass kind of grew up and we would just
put our sleeping bags on the trampoline
and it was kind of funny because like
when you put your sleeping bags on the
trampoline even though you're you're
small I wasn't small but you're
relatively light boys you know the
nature of a trampoline is just high
middle and so by the by the middle of
night you're both kind of like right up
against and your sleeping bags and the
thing I things I remember I've been is
his sense of humor was so silly yeah
like it was just this we would sit out
there and we would tell we would tell
each other jokes was make up jokes yeah
and they were always horrible jokes that
like didn't have punchlines there was
very anti comedy but you would achieve
some sort of delirium
oh we would start laughing yeah just so
uncontrollably couldn't stop having
those like laugh attacks where you just
you
can't stop me like what I don't remember
what you said I don't your joke probably
wasn't good yeah we're not I don't
remember it now he was funny though any
you know he watched Letterman he watched
Carson he would stay up late and do that
and that's just something that I just I
wasn't allowed to do and I didn't it was
it was scary to stay up late I'm not
going to do that but yes and I do
remember he went through this spell I
mean people talk about the innuendo a
good mythical morning it's like he was
the king of that oh yeah I remember that
like in in grade school the kids I mean
the teachers would say something and all
right so and so you need to come up to
the front and he would just start
laughing and he would like look at us
and like he I remember he had this like
he had a dirty mind and I he would he
would love laughing at things that were
like forced innuendos and we went
through this season of really reveling
in the innuendo I remember that well I
still revel in it was it wasn't a stage
and he was in you throughout my entire
life he was such a smart guy I mean I
think he did end up reading a lot and he
had that computer at in the back of the
house there and again I come over there
one day and the two of you had been
working on a from scratch computer coded
role-playing game that you set me down
and I was like the first user to just
like test out your role-playing game it
was only text-based
well you know it spent hours on well we
had space we spent we would revisit it
it was called the Isle of Redmond okay
which was not very creative we just
combine our two names and I think that
it was a you know it was just basic
programming and I don't get I don't know
how Ben learned how to do this but he I
remember sitting at his house one time
and once I kind of understood basic
programming I remember he just went to
sleep one night and I stayed up like
almost all night just
trudging away it like it was a
choose-your-own-adventure game so it's
like you had to create these trees
decision trees and I was like all right
if Rhett Ben decides that he's going to
kill this dragon then this is gonna
happen and I think if you actually
looked at the layering of this thing it
probably only had like four decision
points but that creates I don't know how
to do that math off the top of my head
but it creates a number of potential
outcomes and there's some where you
would die and there was some where you
would keep going and do you remember
what happens if you win because it was a
color monitor no the screen would flash
basically like 12 different colors over
and over again and I think that it
played some tones that was like some
little celebration music just like every
other video game of that age I never got
to the end
exactly but like I've never beaten one
video game and again and then that that
turned into like once I understood that
thanks to Ben is when I end up writing
that game on the calculator that was the
adventure of Merle Haggard yeah I just
wrote my senior year that you had to go
into prison and get Merle I would have
never done any of that thing because the
thing that bent like we had we kind of
wanted to be before her a lot of prison
we had an appetite for this kind of
thing and once she kind of gave us the
opportunity had the avid hook it yeah
but he had the knowledge yeah I think
that's the thing that Ben had he not he
didn't just have the appetite for it he
had the ability he would find the way to
do it and we were just like ah we got
this guy that knows how to do this stuff
so he's just gonna tell us what would
the next thing that we're doing he was
uninhibited sometimes we would go over
there and we were all into rap music and
he would find these interesting rap
songs that weren't so mainstream like
listen to this Boosh nichkhun song and I
developed this dance and he would then
go into this he would teach us to I
would call it so great I would call it a
jig it was like mostly in the in the
hips knees and ankles well it was this
particular dance and he would
do these dance things that look like
kind of look like what Will Ferrell did
as elf in them in the basement of the of
the publisher but I'm in the three of us
would sit there and try to dance do you
remember the time we went over there and
he was like I figured out how to do the
Roger Rabbit
yeah yeah the Roger Rabbit is when you
put your well at least we may have been
wrong but it was when you basically put
your feet behind each other and you're
like doing this thing and you're slicks
you're stepping and it's not easy to do
yeah and like we sit there and like go
on the go in the driveway and like try
to I mean when you're in middle school
it's like I mean you had if you're not
uninhibited you're not gonna sit there
and invent a dance and if you are you're
not necessarily gonna invite your boys
over to like teach them well because
this is something that the girls did
like when they were the cheerleader
girls they would get together and do
their cheer late is it ironically
tik-tok changing that yeah aren't people
like till the tick tock tick tock that
would have been a would have been
amazing at it yeah music was a big part
of what we were doing and he's the one
who then bought a drum machine now we
had already done some talent show
performances as we've talked about
before you know we would Lincoln I would
the story I'm gonna tell is the seventh
grade talent show
right but what we would do before the
drum machine is we would just sing along
with a track yeah and so we would just
we would play like a Digital Underground
song or whatever and we would we would
sing it but then Ben gets this like
Yamaha I don't know what brand it was
drum machine which was basically this
you know black drum machine with I
remember for yeah pads pads you played a
bunch of things that you could play the
drums but then you can also kind of
program some beats yeah I had some
built-in beats as well
he could also beatbox yeah better than
us but we would all do it that was
something that we did in our spare time
I remember seventh grade I got the job
of being the guy who set up the
microphone
and Ben also got the job we work
together whenever there was an assembly
Buies Creek elementary school we would
go and we would we'd get out of class 15
minutes early because we had to set up
the microphones and testimony make sure
they worked before whatever the assembly
was and so we spent a lot of time
setting them up and then when the when
the talent show rolled around and there
was like rehearsals for that we would
hang out in setting up the microphones
for the rehearsal and as seventh graders
it was our first year to be able to
participate in this talent show which we
worshiped the seventh and eighth graders
who would perform an amazing rap song
the previous year's so we finally yeah
we performed same song by digital
underground and then Ben was a part of
that and I remember we were setting up
the microphones and then we we had
either we were about to we had just done
a rehearsal and we go backstage well I
go backstage and I I noticed that Ben is
crying I I don't know that I'd ever seen
Ben cry you know and I was like hey hey
man it's okay we're gonna you know we're
gonna do great we're gonna kill it we're
gonna kill it it's how it's show like
we're I'm feeling I'm feeling good about
this the first graders are gonna love us
we know the words your beatboxing is
amazing and this drum machine makes you
look totally legit man and he said
that's that's not it and he said I said
well what's what's what's wrong and he
said I don't worry about it
and he he didn't tell me what was wrong
but then I remember you told me days
after this that your mom had given you
the news after talking to Ben's mom that
he was sick and and we had seasick we
had noticed that Ben would you know miss
a day of school yeah but that wasn't
that
usual but it was happening it was more
frequent than you would yeah I got
increasingly frequent expect and but it
it's not anything that he talked about
you know he didn't he didn't he didn't
want to he didn't want to bring it up
but as it turns out he eventually would
tell us that the doctors diagnosed him
with chronic fatigue syndrome which at
the timing it's still a very they still
have last I checked they don't have a
whole lot of understanding about this
disease it's sort of like one of those
you know like Lyme disease used to be is
I don't know exactly don't know exactly
what it this is and this might just be a
name for a family of different
conditions or whatever but this was the
beginning of people talking about it in
the mid-90s so any order that actually
the early 90s and it was so which it was
also he's got no idea what's going on it
was discussed at times of kind of being
a catch-all for when you don't know
exactly what's wrong with someone too
but you know that they're extremely
fatigued I mean he described some
mornings not being able to get out of
bed I do remember him telling us at one
point in seventh grade he said sometimes
he could barely crawl to the bathroom in
order to use the bathroom and we
couldn't even believe it we didn't know
how is it we never saw this for like we
never saw it firsthand he didn't he
didn't look well he started to look more
frail but when we would call him and say
hey do you want to do something
sometimes the answer would be no but if
the answer was yes it would be we would
be able to go on our adventures yeah we
would show up and he we'd hop on our
bikes and we'd go play just like we
always had in eighth grade then that was
seventh grade in eighth grade when when
school started back he he didn't come
back right and I said that he was gonna
be basically homeschooled yeah from that
point on and I remember you know this
was I've never been good at processing
this type of information I'm still not
good at it
like when somebody's like going through
something I'm like I don't know how to
comfort you right now he's like that
part of my brain was damaged or
something you know it's like I and I
remember being like this is this guy
that we've spent all this time with we
we've we've we've done all this stuff
with and and all of a sudden it's like
he's not he's not at school and he's
sick how could how could someone as like
has with a so vibrant that has so much
zest for life how could they be the ones
drained of life it just it did not add
up it was well and there was something
else couldn't believe it well and the
interesting thing that was happening as
well and this is like a tale as old as
time is that we were kind of we were
kind of moving along with what it was
like to be in middle school and we
thought I was I had a girlfriend yeah I
got a girlfriend and it was like that
for a while that was the only thing that
was definitely your world
yeah and ever you got a girlfriend yeah
and so it was like okay I'm plan plan
playing basketball and thinking about
high school I'm thinking about all the
girls in high school I got my girlfriend
right now we were doing those sort of
middle school things and it wasn't that
the you know going to the river and
fishing and swinging on vines and
camping and all this stuff was it
something that we wanted to keep doing
but it had it wasn't everything to us
anymore it was something that we did
when we could write and so because we
couldn't so it was interesting because I
you know I felt like that because of
love you have asked the question like
you linked my best friends you've been
best friends this whole time right it's
like yeah we we have been best friends
but it wasn't like it was me and you and
nobody else
yeah and in a lot of ways me and Ben
were closer and for a few of those years
like in like third fourth fifth grade
yeah and then as he started kind of
dealing with his stuff in me and you
kind of continued on living
a quote-unquote normal life that was
kind of unencumbered by the kind of
issues that he was facing then we
basically like our friendship kind of
just superseded every other friendship
and it's been that way ever since yeah I
mean I definitely remember feeling on
the outskirts of the trio you know it
was like I said I would show up to
things and kind of have to I would
gather what I had missed you know I I
think it's fair to say that for for that
period of time we were best we don't
know I think I think we were best
friends but you were best or friends the
two of you yeah it wasn't something we
thought about yeah and we were no list
being made right and there was no
discussions about that but yeah I I
could feel that a little bit but again
it was because I you know I knew it
wasn't calculated Ben was the the
kindest most welcoming person of all
anyone we had met at that age you know
there's it was impossible to hold
anything against him so I didn't feel
jealous like I said I felt I felt
privileged to be invited as this the
scared kid who wasn't adventurous it's
kind of brought along for the ride and
kind of ushered out of my shell so to
speak so but it you know it was
difficult living on the other side of
Buies Creek and knowing that there was
probably stuff going on there were a
frames being built and there were there
were fish being caught in that you know
I wasn't a part of it but as we got
older I was increasingly a part of it
and then has been started wasn't able to
do as much then I think we but we got
even closer and closer to what so but so
kind of fast forward a little bit so in
high school high school got you know I I
have a lot of regrets about the amount
of time that would pass between seeing
Ben yeah and I would hear my mom like
would talk to his mom and we find out
that like all Ben's really struggling
with the chronic fatigue and you know he
basically didn't get
bed this week or whatever and then she
would be like you should you need to go
see him mm-hmm
and it was interesting because because
again I'm I'm not making this I'm not
making an excuse
I felt so inadequate to engage and be
like I know we're not gonna go over
there and like go do something fun I'm
gonna sit there and were gonna talk
about what he's what he's doing supposed
to sit beside his bedside I don't Big
Ben Ben gave the impression he didn't
want us to see him that way
yeah and you know I also regret not not
saying you know what it's it's fine yeah
you know I I want to hang out with you
even if that just means sitting in your
room but we didn't really have a I don't
know we didn't have a track to go on
it's like okay this is how you do it
this is how you empathize with somebody
you know I do wish to your parents
credit to your mom's credit she was like
hey you need to you need to go see him
and you did yeah and then I would hear
about it again I felt a little bit more
on the outskirts of it but it kind of
felt was intimidating but it felt like
it was it was like Oh what are we gonna
talk about now yeah because I'm doing
all these really typical high school
things you know it's like what am I
gonna talk to Ben I'm supposed to talk
about all the stuff that you can't do
right and so the the times between
visiting each other would just get
longer and longer and then but there
would still be times throughout high
school that we would get together
I think am I am I right about this I I
do I remember sometimes yeah Ben became
famous for his running which was
extremely odd given everything we've
told you he would he always wore these
duck shoes now a duck boot you know it
is a lace-up boot that the whole bottom
is that like rubber so it's waterproof
those were his signature shoes the only
type of shoes he wore were duck shoes
and he wore low top duck shoes where it
had like three three eyelets on either
side or two and you
lace it up he would not wear socks and
he would wear those duck boots but that
was supposed to keep water out but like
he would walk through stuff in the water
would be all going all in it he wouldn't
care but he would run for miles he would
jog around he would jog around keith is
in these shoes and he was such an odd
bird right and everybody everybody knew
oh there goes bin he's got chronic
fatigue syndrome yet he's running around
you know it's what I mean and I don't
know again I don't know we never talked
a lot about that period of in his life
but my understanding is that he would
have good days and bad days yeah and so
it's like okay I've got energy today I'm
gonna I'm I'm going out I'm gonna run
yeah and and there and we would get
together it was just increasingly
infrequent as we got into high school
and okay and one of the other things
that was happening and we talked a
little bit about this in the last year's
is like we were basically becoming very
very serious about our faith we started
the band and so this is this was
beginning to kind of consume us and be
it was it was the way we talked to our
time I'd say it it eight oh it didn't he
no no no I'm consumed are tired yeah
yeah I'm but I'm saying that our lies
began our passions much more oriented
towards God especially with the band
yeah we spent as much time as we could
as a band you started neglecting your
basketball I mean we were talking more
about being filmmakers too so it was
like those two passions were and then
whoever whatever girlfriend you had
pretty much filled you to capacity yep
I'm not gonna take the bail that way
yeah the the interesting thing that was
happening with Ben is that he had always
been this again he's the one that had
the knowledge about things right and as
he had all this time on his hands where
he was basically not able
to kind of get up and do things
physically the dude was reading and
Nimet by this point he was on the
internet all the time and he would
occasionally just kind of mention
something that would get that I would be
like wow Ben is in a different place
seriously he did go to church with us
he's got lots of thoughts about this
stuff thoughts that were to me sort of
like kind of like where's he getting
this information because this isn't what
this isn't what we're talking about in
youth group this isn't this isn't
Orthodox hey you know what I'm saying
yeah and so we have always had this kind
of sense that like um you know Ben is
kind of just he's kind of his own guy
and you know I definitely don't think he
would call himself a Christian and that
was becoming more and more important to
us so then there was another sort of a
new roadblock source to that tension or
this friendship yeah this I'm gonna talk
to him about this stuff because we were
developing this conviction that we
needed to share the gospel with our
friends I mean this is why we started
the band and we did invitations at our
concerts like we were invite her
we wouldn't invite our friends out to
watch us play and then at the end we
would we talked about this in the Lost
years but we would go into this thing
where it's like all right everybody bow
your heads and we're gonna pray give you
the opportunity to accept Christ that's
what we were doing with our friends and
so Ben's sort of ideas that were that
seemed different and challenging began
to be I would say even intimidating to
me mm-hmm
fast forward a little bit more we go to
college we go headfirst into Campus
Crusade we've told that story so if you
yeah if you superimpose that on you know
I well I got an email address I would
email Ben occasionally yeah at that
point it would kind of resorted to email
we were off at school he was still back
at home I think he took classes like
college classes from home if I remember
correctly yeah but
so you know there would be a couple of
emails back and forth every month or two
and I remember in it wouldn't be the
three of us he would I would talk to him
you talked to him separately right we
didn't understand Cece right we didn't
read interest and threats it wasn't a I
remember him saying one time he's like I
I like getting emails from you because
you write like you talk that made me
feel really good I don't know what it
was but I for some reason I remember
that specifically but it wasn't it was
the emails were far enough in between
that every time we would restart an
email exchange it would kind of be
ketchup so it wasn't like we were having
an active relationship it was more like
let's let's make sure we know what's
going on in each other's lives a little
bit but again the more you share about
your life the more you feel like you're
sharing things that he might not be
experiencing or isn't able to well I
just that's like is that it's hard
our lives were more and more about
ministry and what in growing in our
relationships with Christ it was like
that was what it was about and I
remember we would have these email
exchanges and I would you know I'd say
something about what I might be doing
and then he kind of gave he would give
these he had these perspectives and
these like interesting thoughts about
things but I just I couldn't engage with
him and again there was just this to the
the the time between correspondents
continued to increase
then I went to if it's in terms of the
way that I can interact it would been
and while I was in college 98 I went on
a summer project what came is crusade in
New York City as I talked about and of
course that time when you're when you're
that age and you've sort of put yourself
in this situation where you've been
doing nothing but ministry for two
months and it's been all about sharing
the gospel with people and you've
learned how to do that very well and
with the on campus crusade what that in
Campus Crusade that kind of means taking
people through a presentation of the
gospel which we called the four
spiritual laws and I think now they call
it the would you like to know God
personally booklet and it's probably
something different now but essentially
it's a short easy to digest booklet that
sort of explains the truth of the gospel
in a digestible way that people can then
make a decision on the spot you remember
what they are what God has a wonderful
plan for your life to all ascend we are
we are sinful and therefore separated
from God 3 Christ died and paid the
penalty for our sins so that we could
re-establish the relationship with God
if point for you make a decision to
place your faith in what Christ did on
your behalf
say ago maybe I just saved some people
so I but it was that it was that concise
yeah right and so it would it made it
very shareable which was again the the
evangelistic part of yeah and so one of
the things I was thinking when I got
back from New York as I was like Ben was
really on my heart where I was like this
guy I love this guy and he's not a
Christian and I've got to share the
gospel with him I got to it is my it is
my it is my I am mandated to share the
gospel with this guy and I was like I
agree he was you know you're we're both
grill girlfriends with him but you know
you were even closer for friend than I
was so this is on you and as we both
don't mean to do it now okay like I'm
gonna tell you what seems like it would
be really tough I'm gonna tell you what
I did and I'm gonna kind of give you my
perspective on it later
so when over there and you had one of
our sort of like awkward conversations
and I'm kind of caught up with him and
what he had been doing kind of told him
about my summer and just said hey
there's something that I'd like to share
with you that I think is really
important and then I basically break out
the booklet and walk him through it and
then I think he just said something at
the end like the whole point is that
you're supposed to bring people to
appoint a decision you don't want to you
want to close the sale essentially you
know you want people to say yes or no
and if they say yes you want to be
located what would you like to pray to
receive Christ right now
Ben was Ben was a little too smart to
get to that point to say just he wasn't
gonna he way he wasn't gonna let me get
to that point right meaning he was he
was smart enough to know what you were
what you were trying to solve what was
happening because he knew that he didn't
want to make the decision he was smart
enough to like to circumvent the the
awkward ending to tactfully and kindly
say I'll think about it
basically now I find it very ironic that
we got this guy who is was so so more
knowledgeable about so many things than
I was
who we'd had this this rich experience
and he had taught me so many things and
I had done all the this is these
adventurous things with him because he
he had gone and he had done the research
and he he had read all this stuff mm-hmm
and then I go away and I come back with
a booklet pamphlet really I come back
with a one-size-fits-all pamphlet
instead of having a real conversation
I'm like you want to go through this
booklet together yeah to me it just feel
it I cringe thinking about it now not
because I was ashamed of the gospel at
the time I wasn't it was I thought that
it was the everybody needed to hear it
but the impersonal unloving nature I I
would say in the way that I did it
though didn't take into account
circumstances I think that covers a real
conversation I think it was very loving
and very cringy I don't think it was
unloving I think it was the best that
you could do based on the convictions
that you held okay and I don't think and
I think that Ben knew that so and he
knew that he'd
did not want to make that decision so he
graciously let you off the hook you know
but I just felt like I felt like a
hypocrite because there's like hey man I
went oh I I lived a life I did all this
this cool stuff I kind of saw you when
my mom told told me to come see you and
then I go off and I come back and I'm
like hey and I've got this I've got the
good news I've gone off I figured this
stuff out I know everything that there
is to know about the secret to the lot
to the good life basically and it's all
in this book here it is let's go through
it together and it just I to me
I'm offended on behalf of Ben when I
think about it but he was gracious and
he took it like a friend in a loving way
yeah and at least you at the time I feel
like at least you could could share that
much you know the ball was in his court
as if maybe he didn't know those things
before you shared them I think is how I
felt about it you know all you can do is
share and then you leave the results to
God but you feel you feel this you know
this tremendous pressure to to share
until you have and then there's at least
relief like hey I've done my part
you know but then in retrospect you look
at all the context and you start to have
the feelings that you just shared and I
I totally get that
I mean I didn't have that conversation
at that point we both had you know other
things that we'll talk about
very soon but from there it was yeah I
mean when we graduated we got married I
don't I don't think Ben was able to come
to my wedding did Ben come to your
wedding no I don't think so yeah I don't
think so either
but I think that there was still the
occasional you know like maybe once a
year we would see him and it would be
like
I feel so bad that it's been so long
since I've seen you you know you're
still you have this condition and you're
at home and I've moved all of my life
now I'm married now I'm having kids now
I'm I'm I'm leaving my engineering job
and I'm joining the staff of Campus
Crusade now I'm leaving Campus Crusade
I'm at I think there would be these few
and far between touch points it's like
this is how my life continues to move
forward and there were the occasional
emails abate and based on the
conversation that we have we had sort of
established sort of a dialogue about
philosophical spiritual things and so
occasionally he would send something hmm
that was you know he was he was doing
all kinds of research about all kinds of
things and he was he wasn't closed off
by any means he would reach out to let
me know that he had read something or he
had this thought about Jesus or whatever
yeah but I definitely had this this
guilt that I think is well-founded that
like someone who was so important to me
that I just didn't make time for and if
I did make time it was like it was there
was so this weight of like this one
issue loomed large in my mind and and
was kind of like the maybe the real
reason I I ultimately Rican would
reconnect over time was because this
looming issue like eternal destiny yeah
he's not saved and then you know we we
eventually leave staff and we start we
start our careers I mean we started
working in in the basement in Lillington
and and making our videos from there as
we as we got going some of the exchanges
that we'd have with him again by that
point we were in Lillington we were 10
minutes away from his house yeah and
then it was like yeah we should see Ben
you should go by and see him but we got
to work
we got to work and then I got to go I
got to drive the opposite direction 15
minutes in order to like help with the
baby and like you know continue to do my
life because there's so
much going on in my life but I know that
he knew about the work we were doing he
got a big kick out of the songs that
we'd write and like the the music videos
that we would make and so like there'd
be some email exchanges there do you
remember when we got the news like how
he heard I don't I don't remember
specifically either but we I yes I I
don't remember how we heard but we heard
from someone and it was kind of going
around the county that like Ben was sick
it's like well yeah Ben kind of always
been sick no Ben is really sick Ben's
got cancer
Ben has cancer is it connected well
people didn't know you know and then you
do we go see him I have to think we went
and saw him when we when we got that
news that he had cancer
at his house I definitely think as he
started to get worse it was it was
testicular cancer him that very quick
that moved very quickly by the time that
they had caught it it had did it spread
and it was really bad and then we we
once we found out we saw him a few times
at his house and every time he was
looking worse and worse and then we got
the the word yeah I mean do you remember
visiting him at his house I honestly I
not until after we had visit him visited
him at hospice they put him in Hospice
which was basically an end-of-life care
yet you're dying so we're gonna make you
as comfortable as possible and we're
gonna give you around-the-clock care in
a facility which now was in Lillington
oh and it was it was it was on our way
from a mile from our he would carpool
from Fuquay office and we'd go past this
facility hang a right and then go to our
our studio so
you know the plan was well at least once
a week we'll go by and see him I think
is what we you know it's like we were
scrambling we were trying to make make
our make our lives work but on our way
into work we can go by there and see him
for an hour so it's I mean it's if
you've never seen anybody in Hospice
it's kind of it's like a hospital room
there's a hospital bed in there and I
don't know how long he was there I my
recollection is that it was a few months
I don't think so
maybe it's six weeks you think it might
have been four weeks I in my
recollection he was there for a few
weeks and then they were like well he's
gonna he's gonna pass away and so we
want that to happen at his house and so
they basically put the hospital bed and
everything in the house downstairs but
so to kind of get get you know there was
this there's a lot of guilt associated
with you know having
having not seen him
and but the the main thing that we were
thinking about was this guy's gonna die
yeah and we got and we gotta save him
yeah we saw him I mean we would visit
him we visited him a few times and it
was it was he was doing bad but it was
he was he always had a smile for us he
has hit his same sense of humor that he
always had he would crack a joke
something about his balls because that
was where the cancer started yeah I
remember him saying you know he he said
do you want to see it [ __ ] and then he
you know he just had a hospital gown on
if we like looked at each other it was
just the three of us in that room and
we're like I guess and he can't you know
he had this this smile on his face like
this is this is funny
and then he like he showed us his
testicle that was like his big as an
orange yeah I mean like and then he made
a joke about it and we laughed because
that's who he was
and he he had the ability to do that and
then he said if you if you think
something's wrong don't ignore it
because that's what I did yeah
and I I think I think that may have been
in our last visit well what I remember
is that we would go see him and then
every time we saw him we would turn the
conversation towards spiritual things so
regardless of how it started
we like been you know I know we haven't
talked about it that that much I know I
talked about to talk to you about this
when we were in when I was in college
but you know have you thought about your
eternal destiny have you thought about
where you're gonna go
or we might just say it I don't remember
exactly I was said it but I think some
ways it was more like well you know that
God loves you and you know we would say
things that were more like encouraging
platitudes
well III suppose I mean the way I
remember it I would ask him questions
like what do you think about God now
yeah where are you at with the way that
you think about Jesus and you know this
dude thought a lot about the spiritual
things and he had a spirituality he
wasn't an atheist he was definitely I
would say he was agnostic because he had
this thing I didn't know and he just
used like I just I just don't know and I
remember one time basically pressing I
was like this is I know this is
offensive and this as tough and the dude
is dying but this is his soul is worth
it yeah and and I think in this
particular time we had the sense that it
was close to the end for him we had been
talking about in our previous visits his
preparations he had he said I want you
guys I want you guys to sing at my
funeral yeah and we were like oh gosh
okay and he said I want you to sing one
of your funny songs like the corn hole
song like that again that was his that
was his way he was like I think it would
I was like well that's gonna be weird
been he's like he's like that exactly
exactly that's what he want you to sing
the corn hole song at my funeral and he
said you know we said then we want to
well I don't know if he said it if we
said it but he wanted to go to the river
one more time and so I remember we
mentioned that to his parents like you
know he wants to go to the river and
they were like I don't we don't we don't
know if he's able like if we take a
wheelchair and like just take him to the
edge of the river where you guys used to
swim is like if if you think that we
could do that we would want to do that
the next time we visited was after that
conversation and we got a sense that it
was the last time and that's when he he
showed us his balls and made us laugh
and but I remember before he went in his
older sister who we had known our whole
lives said to us guys just just try not
to talk about religious religion like
that's how she put it well it was like I
don't want you to I think we don't we
don't want ups we don't want to upset
him at this point in his process well I
think what was happening is you know he
loves seeing us but we were so
singularly focused on bringing him to
hopefully helping him that we fell the
conversation would get I I recall one
time where I really I just really
pressed in and I and I and I said Ben
you know what do you have to lose if
just just pray a prayer with us to make
this this is the last meeting yeah and
but this was the last meeting before his
sister told us to not talk about it
anymore because we did we honored that
and what happened was is he said I don't
know I don't know I can't be sure and he
started crying yeah and you know the
thing is is at the time I felt bad but I
was like well crying a little bit now is
not anything compared to what'll happen
to him he doesn't make this decision I
mean that's the logic that was happening
in my brain
yeah and we had talked about it ahead of
time that we had to do we just felt like
we had to be as clear as possible and do
everything we could to help him so this
I was not blindsided by you pressing him
I would we had agreed agreed upon it
yeah and I I mean we would leave those
meetings and I would just bawl em like
on the on the way back home
you know feelings feeling responsible
for that
yeah and worrying about him but his
sister told us the next time we went and
she said you know but you said you
pressed him and that I mean to pray with
us right yeah so yeah that's what you
meant by that was well I don't remember
exactly how we said it but it was you
know it you don't have to know it's just
let's just pray and you can we can pray
something you can repeat after us and
you can you can accept Jesus I mean and
he said okay and he you know it was
basically we we prayed you know and it
was it's one of those things that like
you can look at it at the time afterward
and say okay I feel I feel relieved me
maybe that did it I feel I mean the
words were right you we can't control
like what's going on in his heart but
you know he did say the words and it was
kind of reduced to that like yeah we
from an outsider's perspective you might
think of it as like a magical
incantation that's not how we thought of
it but it was if he was sincere in his
heart then then that then he was saved
he only God knows
so yeah I don't know if he you know but
he gave us or if he did it for him and
but the thing is is that or both he
probably you know it's just so hard to
process because it gave us this sense of
closure that okay all right we did
everything we could
and I do think that we were acting out
of love because of the way that we
thought about the world at the time he
knew that he knew that and you know so
don't blame us for doing something that
was you know I wish we could have spent
I wish we could have spent a different
kind of time yeah
as opposed to like trying to convince
him with something that I don't even
believe anymore you know so there was if
there was one more meeting at the then
that was it I don't recall seeing him
when they moved him back to his house I
again I this may be the the nature of
memory I I have a recollection of
talking to him once in his home but I'm
at I made that maybe something that I've
just created because I've been in his
home so many times and they told me
where the bed was and but I seem to
remember no I think I did talk to him
because he was getting a little
delirious at the end I wasn't there and
he had actually you know he would so he
had like a catheter and then he got up
in the middle of the night and like
walked and didn't realize it was in and
stuff and they were just like it's you
know he was telling me that and he was
kind of talking about it as a funny
story like let me tell you what happened
to me last night but then it quickly got
to a place where you know his mom said
that you know you don't you don't want
to see him like this
he's dying when we got the call it was I
mean we knew the call was coming so we
were blindsided by it and we and I think
at the time we didn't feel we felt like
we had we had done our piece you know I
think that's how we felt about it then
not how we feel about it right now yeah
and yeah they they asked us to - they
said there'll be an opportunity to share
at the graveside service
and either they asked us to sing a song
or we volunteered and said that he does
he asked us to but but we we didn't sing
the corner also we could spoiler alert
sing the cornhole song but we thought
that the perfect compromise was to and
of course this is this has a whole
different meaning now but you know it
didn't at the time to sing the Michael
Jackson song been which is about our pet
rat a killer rat who was the Michael
Jackson's pet yeah and the I pulled up
the lyrics yeah you learned it on the
guitar we sang it in harmony at the
graveside service then most people would
turn you away I don't listen to a word
they say they don't see you as I do I
wish they would try to I'm sure they
think again if they had a friend like
Ben so we made a joke about it being a
song about Michael Jackson and a rat and
which we sorry appropriate for Ben he
would love that and everybody agreed who
was there and it was it was a difficult
song to sing but well and do you
remember what we said because I remember
in addition to the song I remember I
think I know what you're gonna say yeah
again you know the interesting thing is
at the time it wasn't that I wasn't you
know as I said the stories
it wasn't that I hadn't doubted things
pretty significantly at that point but
it hadn't gotten to the core of my faith
yet and so this didn't create a crisis
it created a moment where we had to
believe that the end what he was in
heaven he was in heaven and that's what
I told everybody at that funeral I was
like you know he did have a I didn't
have faith I didn't go into the details
of what the story that happened
I thought that might be inappropriate
but yeah we basically said that you know
again this is one of the things that is
so interesting I've been to lots of
funerals and I haven't I've everyone
I've been to for the most part has been
a Christian funeral you know there's a
certain it's it's it's it's it's ironic
because there's a hope that comes with
faith the idea that people go on and
that you're gonna see people again and
you're gonna see people in heaven which
may be true and but then the flip side
of that is that well if you subscribe to
a particular you know understanding of
Christianity well some people are not
gonna be in heaven they're gonna be in
hell and those funerals are awkward when
someone is not saved and everybody knows
it it's like well it lived a good life
let's tell some let's tell some stories
about him and let's just hope that God
has mercy on his soul essentially which
I just always find so you know I get it
I know I understand it that's the way
you see the world then that's the kind
of the way that you're gonna respond but
for us for Bend because we had gotten
him to the point to pray that prayer we
could have this perspective that was
like been left this world with faith and
that's what that's why we're gonna see
him again and we were able to say that
and I don't know it's it's interesting
because now looking back on it in the
way that I see the world now in I'm like
yeah maybe I'll see Ben again one day I
don't know I don't think that I can know
and I no longer really care that I can
know but I I see what we did was very
much about us I'm not saying we didn't
love Ben I'm not saying we didn't
actually care about him and I'm not
saying that we weren't motivated by a
concern for his soul but I also think
that a part a not insignificant part of
that process was about us feeling good
and being okay
with ourselves and being able to say
that we did our job we did our duty and
now we can get up at the funeral and say
that he's got faith and you know I mean
I don't blame us but I don't like it was
the majority selfish I think they were I
think there were elements that I think
that we just we needed to have that hope
because we loved him so much
yeah and we wanted to share it because
we wanted to say something at the
funeral because if there was anybody we
wanted to to help anyone else that felt
the same way that we felt yeah but I
don't know how it made his family feel
and it probably didn't made him make him
feel better and I also I think they
understood yeah they I think they
understood that our hearts were in the
right place but they were already
hurting so much it was like I I do I
think they gave us a benefit of doubt
because I mean listen I could think that
they lived in Buies Creek North Carolina
for a long time and they knew that we
were sincere believers who cared about
this guy and saw the world in that way
and just wanted to see him come to faith
I think it probably was a little bit
annoying because I don't know I don't
know where the where they are where they
were at the time but I have it they
always seem to be really thoughtful
people who didn't just back we s to the
status quo which the status quo in Buies
Creek was you're gonna be a
bible-believing Christian and so III do
I you know I don't know I I feel like
there's a part of me that wants to
apologize you know I think that you know
in these on behalf of my former self in
these my thought on that is in these
books you know as we shared at the top
we really we really saw to honor Ben
because of how important he is to us
but I do think that there's also a part
of it that's like it's the best we can
do to make amends for the for the
regrets that we have and again it's not
just the spiritual stuff but it's just
you know not being capable of being the
friend that that he deserved you know in
over many years since his diagnosis is
original diagnosis and you know so I I
think that I think it's been our best
effort to to honor him and to but yeah I
am sorry for and I know he forgave us
you know I we did discuss it at his
bedside we told him we were sorry for
not being there for not being there for
him and he forgave us that's the kind of
person that he is and you know so I
think that everything that we do he he
touches and I think that's the that's
the best we can do to to honor and it's
what we are what we have done yeah I
think the only thing I'll add to that is
that you know we don't know we don't
know what's next after this life but
there's one thing I do know what
certainty is that Ben lives on and his
legacy is what we try to honor and what
we try to my body
and with that I'll give a recommendation
which is along these same lines okay
we've all got we've all got bins in our
lives and it doesn't have to be somebody
who you know is sick or is dying it
might be but just somebody who has been
a friend and impacted you and maybe some
circumstances of life have led you away
from them and you haven't connected with
them in a while make an effort to
connect with
okay well thanks for listening and if
you want to contribute to this
conversation you know what to do hashtag
ear biscuits and will will talk at you
next week and probably not cry last week
I dunno
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]